Well, here we are.
What the hell is going on?
Well, Ron's
going to tell us.
-Hello, Ron.
-Hi.
-Last task.
-Let's do it.
Would you mind reading it out
nice and clearly?
So bittersweet.
"Wearing your blindfold
at all times,
inflate and tie
the biggest balloon.
Biggest balloon wins.
You have 100 seconds."
-Really nice reading.
-Thank you!
You can't see for this task
at all,
so if you'll put
your blindfolds on, please.
It's weirdly tense,
isn't it, Reggie?
It is.
Unusually so.
This is the final task
of the season,
and anyone -- nearly anyone --
two people could win the season.
Okay?
[ Laughter ]
So, good luck, everyone.
[ Whistle blows ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's big.
Aw, damn.
♪♪
[ Balloon pops ]
Where are you?
Five, four,
three, two, one!
[ Whistle blows ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, Ron?
Here, you dropped this.
-Oh!
-Very nice.